here it is my friends the mustache
around the world
[Music]
mission impossible fallout I have seen
it I am gonna review it but first I'm
gonna take a quick second to explain why
the thumbnail looks the way that it did
it's because paramount is a bunch of
jerks
and they have laid copyright claims on
videos that I have done talking about
movies that they come out for the use of
a few seconds worth of a promotional
image not video not audio a still image
and they let copyright claim
and yes I know I feel I'm well within my
rights for to continue to dispute a fair
use I did the initial dispute they
continued to say no this is ours
we're claiming this whole video and you
know the video I'd like to take a stand
on the principle of it I can't afford to
I can't afford to lose even though I
know I'm right and it's not worth the
stress so I'm avoiding stressing and
from forever after anytime I talk about
anything being released by Paramount I
can't use images and I'm not gonna
they're gonna get big old question mark
so from really feeling spiteful maybe
I'll hand draw some doodles okay now
that I've gotten that off my chest let's
actually talk about this movie cuz this
movie though distributed by a bunch of
jerks it's not the fault of the film so
let's assess the film as it is so how is
Mission Possible follow well it looks
like it was made by a bunch of jerks no
I'm okay I'm done I'm done with that bit
it's good maybe a little bit of a
history of my feelings about the mission
impossible franchise in general I've
never done a review of any of the others
well I sort of did Mission Impossible
rogue nation made my top ten movies of
that year when I did my annual list I
can't think of the year now off the top
my head was 2015 2014 hey whatever it
was so I do like this franchise and I've
liked it since the beginning so like my
general feelings there's only one
flat-out bad mission
possible movie and that's the second one
my favorites are actually honestly the
even number and sorry the odd-numbered
ones I like one I like three I like five
ghost Protocol it that's the fourth one
it's okay I think it got really over
praise I think because everybody was
still really high on Brad Bird and like
it was his live-action debut so people
kind of like the the the geek circles
kind of went nuts and I said it's fine I
don't think it's one of the better ones
so now we have Mission Impossible
follows and I was nervous going into
this for a couple of reasons one
superstitiously it's an even number and
I haven't liked the even-numbered ones
as well and I was afraid we were looking
at an opposite of the Star Trek movie
curse thing but then in addition to that
this was the first time that they
brought back a director from the one
preceding it and the first time they
picked up on plot threads from the ones
before
we've had a handful of recurring
characters well basically three and
maybe a cameo somewhere I mean Ethan
Hunt you know Tom Cruise he's always
there and Luther is usually turned up
and then you know we've we've had Benji
since three but you know a handful of
recurring folks but it's usually more or
less a clean slate every time so the
whole idea of having this play out the
threads from what had gone on in rogue
nation and bringing Chris McQuarrie back
his writer director who and he did a
great job on rogue nation but the whole
thing made me nervous because one of the
things I did like about this series was
the fact that they brought in a
different director each time and gave it
a little bit of a different flavor again
didn't always work to but I still
enjoyed it so now having seen this to
sort of place it within the scope of the
franchise it's not as good as five rogue
nations still my favorite I don't know
if I like one or three
this comes in after that I think it's
better than booking Ghost Protocol but
again I think I'm in the minority on my
assessment of that film in the first
place but it's definitely way better
than - it needs about in the middle it's
good and it surely didn't disappoint the
way that I was afraid their first kind
of direct follow-up would disappoint it
is it is a breakneck film don't you know
what this only just occurred to me this
is the movie that Quantum of Solace
wanted to be and totally fail - so the
whole thing where we've got some strands
playing out we get a little bit from a
villain that we dubbed that was dealt
with and captured at the very end of the
preceding movie so much back to back to
back to back to action it's not a
dissimilar structure but Quantum of
Solace is crap because the action is
impossible to follow and and you can't
tell what's going on and Mission
Impossible you can follow the action and
it's good and it's fun and it's intense
how's the plot it's about standard for
these I don't really think I could tell
you they're trying to get some nukes
they're trying to get into some nukes I
can tell you that much
but the specific hints outs in terms of
who betrays who why they are about to
pull off the thing that they're about to
pull off and what that will allow them
to do next and how that contributes to
the great a thing I I followed it well
enough while watching I wasn't like
going I don't know going on but I
couldn't like tell you now I couldn't
actually chart it out for you having
seen it but that's not for me at least
that's not really a problem because
these films do a really good balance in
terms of keeping things moving but not
feeling like it's just beating you over
the head with action it knows the points
at which to take a breath have a
character beat have a transition slow
down for just the scene so that we get a
chance to appreciate when the action
gets really high octane and it does give
really high octane I don't think I
wouldn't say these are the best action
sequences like there's nothing quite as
jaw-dropping as like the opera sequence
in rogue nation but it is they are all
really good the bathroom fights is
probably one of the highlights but
there's also a really impressive chase
sequence through the streets of Paris
and it's off to to the Paris police boy
they they gave him a good chase
seriously and it's also nice that we
have a new actual recurring character
because Ilsa Faust who was introduced in
both nations brought back and she was a
big highlight from that from that film
so it was very nice to have her back as
well I'm Henry Cavill as kind of a CIA
heavy he does that he's big and
intimidating and he looks the part he
plays it pretty well yeah I think I
think he needed a part like this I think
he needed to kind of do well in an a bit
of a more utility role because you know
they've been pushing him as a lead
obviously in Superman but also ain't
something like Man From UNCLE which I
didn't see but I heard he was fine in
but the film didn't do especially well
so I think it was good for him that he
got to be in something you know that
that is doing quite well and is well
reviewed I think he probably needed that
and we also get some we get a surprising
number of cool nods to varying degrees
to almost all the other films and I if I
can remember when I start talking a
little bit more spoilers I might go into
specifics all night because some of them
I actually think were really clever and
yeah I mean this this is exactly what it
looks like it is a chance to watch Tom
Cruise just work his body into the
ground he who he takes a beating in this
it some of these things really I mean I
was gonna say they look like they hurt
some of them did he I think he broke an
ankle or something
I mean one of the and one of the jumps
like bit this was this this is a brutal
film and when things hit they heard
there's a really good balance between
the practical and the CGI and very
rarely is there a 100% CGI shot or
effect there is usually a real element
that turns to CGI when something happens
that would not have been in any way
feasible to do real and then it turns
back to live action again as soon as
that part of the shots over so it's CGI
is used to augment a whole lot of
practical stuff which is the way I think
it should be done especially when you're
doing something that is supposedly set
in the real world whereas you can get
away with more complete CGI if you're
going more cartoonish more overblown
than these films tend to be I think
that's about it like it was a good time
I had fun I'm certainly not my favorite
of the series but it was a good time at
the movies so I suppose I'm gonna get
into what could consider to be spoilers
this is probably gonna be pretty brief
because I just kind of want to talk
about some of the nods to earlier stuff
that I really enjoyed I love that we got
the daughter of Max so you got to be an
old fan of this because max was Vanessa
redgraves
character in the first Mission
Impossible and she was a basically a
black market broker kind of person and
her daughter has taken things up in her
stead and I thought that was a cool
little nod and there's there's other
ones kind of sprinkled throughout little
nods to stuff that has been done
including one to number two at least it
felt like one because at the very end to
get the detonator Ethan has to free
climb up a cliff and what was he doing
at that was the ridiculous activity was
doing at the very start of Mission
Impossible 2 free climbing up a cliff
yeah there we go so that's probably the
only spoiler I needed to talk about that
I wanted to talk about really because
like I said it's not a plot heavy well
no that's not true it is plot heavy is
fought heavy in the
spy movies are it's overly twisties
overly complicated but it knows that it
knows to use that over complication as a
way to get us between madcap set-pieces
as opposed to something like last year
when I saw atomic blonde and that movie
was good but it was the ratios were
almost the inverse of this it was way
more backstabbing and intricate plotting
too just a little bit of action and when
it actually bogged the film down and the
plotting and expected us to get invested
and follow everything that was going on
it it got harder to get invested whereas
this I understand it just enough that it
gets me from point A to point B and both
point a and point B are awesome action
sequences so it works so that's mission
impossible fallout oh I had one other
thought when I and this one is spoilery
as well so alec baldwin died and we
should have seen that coming because the
being the director of the IMF we this he
he's only the second one we've seen
killed but we never see them in that
position more than once we kind of sort
of did this time because Alec Baldwin
took on the position officially at the
very end of the previous movie but he
wasn't in that position for the majority
of it so I'm starting to feel like being
the director of the IMF is a bit like
being the defender against the dark arts
professor at Hogwarts you are not going
to be holding that position for very
long so I'll wrap it up on that note
have you seen Mission Impossible follow
what you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it you know
the stuff to do I haven't paid try it's
kind of the big one but there's that and
a whole bunch of other stuff it's all
down in the description check it out if
you feel like it and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]